Chris Pratt and Jimmy Fallon act out a
hilarious game of Mad Libs spanking
the 37 year old actor was a guest on The
Tonight Show Tuesday and things got
ridiculously funny when the passengers
star in the late-night host
took the stage in these festive costumes
to act out their holiday themed Madlib
the reason I worked so hard is because I
get to spread joy to millions of people
and go sit by the fire shaken man and
Chris played the role of Santa Claus as
Jimmy took on the role of a naughty elf
who is being accused of stealing a toy
where were you the night before
Christmas why did Rudolph
see you spanking on the room on an
equally amusing note Chris told Jimmy a
story about his four-year-old son Jack's
recent trip to the Universal Studios
theme park he went and they have a guy
there dressed up like my character from
Jurassic world and he does the thing
with the Raptors and he came home and
he's like dead I met the real Joe
Jurassic world guy
I'm like back dog no I'm the guy he's
like I know no no he didn't he doesn't
do it on TV he's the real guy
[Music]
you